[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
it seems like every single contentious
issue in the country just about
all keeps coming back
to one issue and that would be
education
at the center of the education issue for
the past 35 years there has been one
person that would be the former
secretary of education betsy devos
author of brand new book hostages no
more
the fight for education freedom and the
future of the american child secretary
devos thank you for coming on thanks for
having me michael so
there is this very strange circumstance
which is you've been working on this for
decades education has flown a little bit
under the radar
conservatives talk about it republicans
talk about it it's never been a top tier
issue and now beginning i suppose really
last year and accelerating throughout
the 2022 year
it seems as though education is is at
the heart of the election you see what
happened in virginia education flipped
that race you see florida education's
played a huge role down there
state by state
is this the moment
it is the moment and
the last two years have really laid bare
for
american families across the country
the failings of a 175 year old system
failings that you know i've seen for
many years many others have seen and
tried to change policy around but those
failings have been laid bare be it in
extended shutdowns be it
mandates and mass mandates and you know
in out whatever blended learning
distance learning
and they had a front row seat to all of
this and in many cases they were very
frustrated and very disappointed with
what their kids were experiencing or
frankly not getting in terms of an
education so this is really a key moment
parents are are
riled up and rightfully so and
grandparents and friends and neighbors
are and so it's it's an ideal time to
push forward with policy that will
empower families what do you think
specifically riled them up you gave a
few examples there i've wondered if
transgenderism in the schools the idea
that boys now are going to go into a
girl's locker room as a i'm not a parent
of a daughter and my
my son is not in school yet but i
that would be a red line for me i just
would i could not accept that situation
is it that is it the critical race
theory in the schools is it or was it
just this bizarre experience of covid
where the schools get shut down the
teachers unions keep the kids out for
two years and the parents say enough
i think it's all of the above and in
many cases for families it's a number of
those problems all coming into
confluence with one another for others
it's one of them but in any case there
are any number of issues that have
become apparent to families in ways that
they had never really paid attention to
before or realized before many families
had their kids in schools that they
thought were good places for their kids
to learn
and then they had this front row seat to
what was happening and that was really
uh revelatory for them so they've gotten
involved and they've been told in too
many cases that they should go back
shut you know shut up sit down don't
bother us we know what's best
and uh and you know then we saw the
prospect of the fbi being called out to
turn parents away from expressing their
concerns or asking their questions at
school board meetings that's right you
have
under the biden administration the fbi
the doj come out they both say that
parents
parents just going in and showing up to
their kids schools and saying hey cut
the nonsense
pose a terrorist threat
yeah
yes i mean it it is jaw-dropping to
think that is how we're deploying the
highest
law enforcement agency in our country
to call parents domestic terrorists and
send them you know the fbi into schools
it's just
that i think has also been a huge point
of contention and has awakened other
parents even more to where the emphasis
is in this whole equation it's not on
what's right it hasn't been and it is
not on what's doing what's right for
kids it's been about adults and adult
issues and their vested futures well and
there is the just exposure of the
teacher unions i i suspect you've known
for a very long time i've known for a
very long time that the teacher unions
are
positively villainous they have
destroyed so much of american education
but for your average voter who's not
totally plugged into politics all the
time
probably that wasn't
abundantly clear
until coveted exactly because the school
unions and i think that talk about them
broadly as school unions because they
represent a whole lot more than teachers
and i i would say teachers are sort of a
second thought in that whole equation
with the teachers union but yes they
kept schools closed down way longer than
necessary you know children around the
world were going back to school in the
spring of 2020 and
you know we encouraged
folks to be making plans to get kids
back in school in person in the fall of
2020 and we were accused of playing
politics with covid well it was not
politics with kovit it was out of
concern for what this is doing to kids
kids suffered and we won't know the full
extent of how it has harmed how all of
those closures all of the uh back and
forth in and out how that has
harmed kids in the long run and
especially the kids the most vulnerable
ones who could least afford to be out of
school
this is such a scary point which is we
won't know the effect of what is being
done to kids in schools for quite some
time and it gets back to this issue that
that everyone seems to be focusing on
right this moment in the schools which
is the gender ideology the idea that in
some schools now
a child an 11 year old a 12 year old
could be put on puberty blockers
without parental notification could have
their biochemistry fundamentally altered
because of
it in my view an absurd notion of human
nature and
sexuality
without a parent having any say in this
this is a
life-altering irreversible sort of
how do the schools get away with that
well i don't think they will ultimately
because again
people have awakened to what is
happening
and uh and exposing that and putting
getting it out into the light it will
ultimately have to change behavior on
the part of those
schools and buildings but it will
ultimately help embolden folks who've
been reticent before to support this
notion that parents should ultimately be
in charge of where and how their kids
learn and so i think it's it's it's a
important moment because i i think that
we will never go back to
this uh this you know pre-covered
situation where we just sort of uh
assumed things were doing our kids were
doing well and
we assumed that what they were being
taught was what they needed to know
we've known for a long time before covid
that the system most kids are in has has
not done well and has not helped kids
achieve to the levels they need to we
our international competitiveness is
just
we're not even in the top 10 in any
subject area as compared to
international peers and you know we we
keep spending more and more money but
getting worse and worse results and
again it's the kids who can least afford
it that are the ones being harmed the
most i imagine that you are going to be
a
highly sought after person looking ahead
to 2024.
this is a major issue that's going on
all of the
conservatives worth their salt are
focusing on this issue of education so
if you had some 2024 candidate coming
groveling to secretary devos for advice
what should i do how should i focus my
campaign what would be the first things
you would tell them to focus on i would
tell them focus
focus on
universal
education freedom for every family in
america
and fundamentally changing the system
we've lived with for 175 years it's not
working for the vast majority of kids
and for those for whom it is working it
wouldn't force any change but it would
give the freedom to the families that
don't have it today to make a different
choice and find a different alternative
and place for their kids to learn could
a republican president or even a
well-meaning democrat if we can find one
in in office
could they if enact a federal nationwide
school choice policy
well the policy that they can enact and
which we champion during the trump
administration is an education freedom
scholarship a tax credit at the federal
level
doesn't form another it doesn't create
another federal program it's simply a
mechanism through the department of
treasury for individuals to redirect a
portion of their federal tax bill to
scholarship organizations that will help
families have that freedom that we're
talking about to make choices different
than their assigned schools that's a
great idea i absolutely love that idea
it's a great idea yes
even the conservatives who don't want to
grow the government and don't want to
have a new program it's okay it's not
you're just moving money from a place
where it's probably being wasted to a
place that is so important because it's
not as though education is just some
side issue in the country right the
classroom is it's a crystal ball it
shows you what your country is going to
look like exactly exactly and we have
not had the kind of creativity or the
kind of disruption in the education
industry that we've had in every other
sector of our society and when we do
have that we're going to be amazed at
what the american ingenuity and
entrepreneurship will will create and
cultivate and how that's going to
ultimately help kids who today are
being ill served by their assigned
schools and are
frustrated or bored to death with the
schools that they're going to and it
will it will create a whole different
environment and therefore much better
outcomes and achievement levels which is
important for leadership in the future
for our country now i have a selfish
time problem and it's this i have a 17
month old baby got another baby on the
way they are gonna be five years old
before i know it blink of an eye blink
of an eye and there are not a lot of
great school options around nashville
i've asked people i said where are they
they say even the good schools have gone
pretty woke so i i think
what am i going to do with my kid in the
short term does this mean
i i homeschool my kid and i lose out on
my tax credit how do i do it well if uh
if
if tennessee adopts a statewide
education savings account program you
could access that and take that some or
all of that money to form a little
consortium of homeschoolers with other
families
and
and pay a really great teacher to come
and teach your kids and it you know
having education freedom for kids is
important it's also important for
teachers because really great teachers
can fi they will be the the highly
valued
part of that equation and they'll be
able to find their own niche and their
own place to teach in ways that will
really work for them and it's really an
exciting prospect for teachers as well
this sounds like
when western civilization made sense
when our civilization was growing and
thriving
this is how education was done it wasn't
big institutionalized one-size-fits-all
public schools alexander the great going
all the way back alexander the great
didn't go to a public school did he was
tutored by aristotle okay and people
traditionally who had privilege and had
means
had these small little tutoring
consortia
why can't we give that to everybody
we can and we can do that through the
mechanism of education freedom in the
form of education savings accounts so
each family could take the the dollars
that are already designated for that
child for their education and today we
spend on average fifteen thousand
dollars per child per year some places
it's a lot more in some places it's less
but if you metaphorically attach that to
that child's backpack and let their
family decide how and where that child
is going to learn
we're going to have the creation of
these home school one-room school micro
school environments and it will be
an exciting
growing time for kids that for whom that
approach will work and it will be also a
time for entrepreneurial folks to
take some of the things they've tested
and there's there's been a lot of
interesting educational uh experiments
that have been going on in this country
and i try to highlight many of them that
i visited um in my book but there's been
a lot that's happened but there hasn't
been the ability to scale that or offer
it more broadly because there aren't
enough families empowered to make those
decisions so in a very short time maybe
before your son is five
you could have that opportunity as well
to choose not only a home school but
perhaps a multitude of other
possibilities that would work for him
this sounds marvelous i'm in i want to
sign up wherever i possibly can i
suspect most americans will be in on
this i think this is why the parents
movement has been so effective is that
it appeals not just to republicans not
just to democrats not just a white
people not just a black people not just
a northerner it has a very very wide
appeal
however
there are entrenched interests
the school unions as you i think aptly
call them they're not going to like that
the government bureaucrats are not going
to like that very much and the leftist
activists who have infiltrated these
schools and and
openly i'm not i'm not spouting some
conspiracy theory they've written and
talked about this at length used the
schools to advance their ideology
they're not going to like that either so
how do you overcome that those political
hurdles to
to school choice well you elect people
to office from the federal level to the
most local level who support this notion
of education freedom
and hold them accountable to
uh you know actually advancing those
policies when in office
and uh and defeat the ones that are
opposed to it that's happening in states
across the country now it can happen
more uh more broadly because i think the
parents are going to demand it well this
is something i've always loved about
your approach to politics in particular
there are many people on the right who
unfortunately
they they have a little too much faith
in the free markets or in the culture or
in they just sort of think look we don't
need to focus on direct political action
we'll just we'll just hope it all kind
of works out in the end and that isn't
that isn't really how it works the left
fills every political and government
post
down from the lowest level all the way
up to the top and they exert real
political pressure you have worked
within and on the republican party for
many many years i i
i'm reminded of that line from ernest
hemingway you know he's describing
bankruptcy he says
you go bankrupt gradually then suddenly
well that's true that's true of edifying
things too the movements grow gradually
and then suddenly maybe we're at that
moment right now so how do you
for the regular old
maybe republican listening maybe
conservative activist listening
what do they do practically
practically speaking we have elections
coming up in a few months and there are
candidates running for office from the
federal level to your most local level
check out your candidates positions
support candidates that are going to
vote for advocate for and then vote for
education freedom policies and and
specifically uh ask them what do you
mean if you support education freedom
what does that mean to you and get them
on record as uh
being willing to cast votes for policies
that are going to make that dramatic
change and hold them accountable
are there states that have been doing
this better than other states there are
florida is probably the most
advanced in that regard
for more than 20 years they have
continued to build on policies that then
governor jeb bush put into place i seem
to recall you had a hand in some of
those policies down in florida yes we've
been working in florida for a long time
but there's been uh legislators and
governors who've continued to build on
those original successes
and uh and they're and they're still
committed to more uh freedom and broader
freedom for florida students and i
expect they'll attain that in the next
session or the next year
that's happening there arizona has been
very good indiana has been great
with you know wisconsin and ohio have
continued to expand on programs
tennessee has uh has come along the
supreme court in tennessee most recently
gave approval constitutional
past constitutional muster on the
education savings account program here i
think tennessee has an opportunity to
double down on that and make it a
statewide education savings account
program so that families across
tennessee can access it
so it's happening it's happening many
states 26 states that have some form of
education freedom but not nearly enough
to really
address the demand and the need that has
been become apparent something that
strikes me just hearing you just
describe all of this is
and it's so many people probably don't
know about you who haven't spent time
with you
you have a great deal of humility about
what you've accomplished in politics and
you don't go bragging about it you don't
make a big show about it but you have
been consistently chipping away at this
issue for a long time as you describe
going back 20 years in florida and
elsewhere around the country and people
probably
don't know that
in fact if people have a public
perception of you and they haven't paid
close attention they the perception
probably will be that you are the devil
incarnate because they tuned into cnn
during the trump administration you know
that's absolutely right and
i would encourage them if they'd like to
get a different perspective and
understand how this
this issue has developed over the last
number of years and to see hope for
where we are in time right now and what
we can what we can accomplish in a short
period of time because of the momentum
i encourage them to read the book that i
just uh just finished and i'm really
excited about getting out there hostages
no more
it is a provocative title but it is a
reference to
horace mann the founder of our education
system
175 years ago said that educators are
entitled to look upon parents as having
given hostages to our cause
and so the title hostages no more
suggests
we have got to free our children and
families from
being hostage to that cause the multiple
causes today that we've seen
contrary to families values to their
wishes for their children to their
aspirations for their children and and
and free them to really really pursue
their futures in meaningful ways you
know i have not yet read the book in my
defense it's not out yet i just received
my copy so i i
very much look forward to reading it and
i didn't catch the reference from from
the title but it's a very important one
because a lot of people i think believe
that our problems in education they go
back
20 years 30 years 50 years no they go
back
basically to the very beginning of the
public education movement in america
they go back to people like horace mann
and others yes yes indeed and
when our modern education system was
implemented it was specifically to
educate and form children to become
factory workers and uh in you know
industrial age just to go do the same
kind of job day after day time after
time and again our
society has fundamentally changed and
yet we're still practicing the same
approach to how kids learn
we look at the situation now we say
these kids they're just being churned
out as automatons and we we describe
that as though that's a bug of the
system in fact it was a design it was
the design it was the feature and so
maybe that means we need a different
system exactly secretary devos thank you
very much for the book first of all
hostages no more go get it today the
fight for education freedom and the
future of the american child available
wherever fine books are sold so go be
sure go out and get it arm yourself it's
important for your kids it's important
for your community it's important for
your country and secretary devos thank
you uh thank you so much thanks time
you're in town sounds great thanks so
much
[Music]
[Music]
you